[Music] I'm going to go
out with Mr. Shirakawa Do you
really think you can go out with Mr. Shirakawa? It's
okay, I'll let you dream a little more.
Chirito doesn't need a shower.
What are you saying?  I guess that's all a guy can
think about when he's alone with his girlfriend. I
don't care. I
wonder if he's going to die. Hey Kashima. It's a little old. This is this
guy. The guy I liked so much, Maka, has already graduated.
[Music]
I'm asking for help, but it's the
first time in my life that I've called a child by her first name, so I'm mentally prepared. From
today onwards, I'm my boyfriend. You, who have experience in
TV anime, and I, who have no experience, are going
out with
someone who's off to talk.  What are you doing? It's not that you're
doing something that you can't say to anyone, it's
not that you're doing something naughty.
No.